hello and welcome to the Deo playing
shoe hundra and chuchundra okay got some
kind of banco here i guess i'm with a
six okay so yeah I'm probably just
normal development yeah it seems to be
very intent on opening here I can also
do way forever oh it's taking this jar
maybe because of possible night to
before here
hmm
ja maybe it's not what I expected but
it's playable
is six ok so think I'm done to prevent
Bishop g4 cm
you
yeah let's see strategically speaking
this position is quite dubious for black
are you pawn this week and it's not
quite clear where's counter place he's
got the bishop pair but I don't don't
quite see the concrete ideas here so
might be five maybe in some clay on and
it could be subject to hear right with
night XD five a black has to work with
Trixie otherwise you justice is
completely worse for nothing but maybe
he's active enough that's possible ok
hon IP 594 Quincy one a pawn is more
let's go on but he gets this this
activity with 94 maybe Bishop b4 as a
move him trying to take on d5 it could
be interesting
hmm that's an interesting move maybe
it's good you should befall and it's
taking a long time now yours playing
instant move the whole game up to this
point and now he takes time it is
definitely critical position after
Bishop before I'm not quite sure what
I'm playing it might be that his his has
a good pollution line threatening Bishop
takes d5 No ok so maybe he wants to take
on age 3 here that is yeah that's may be
possible that's may be possible I cannot
take a five Bishop e3 rook a seven is
called Queen g4 hmm now that he has a
definite attack them absolutely
absolutely true after Bishop h3 if he
gets that in turn very interesting
I don't like to play King edge to but
maybe maybe it's what I have to do yeah
okay it looked very dangerous 94 Quincy
19 f to Bishop g7 King g7 queen bee to
check is an important line yes this was
the move that I was initially afraid of
and still don't quite know what to do
against maybe I actually have to allow
him to take here it's it's maybe if what
I have to do very tricky okay I'm taking
this now also having rook 87 as a
possible move after Bishop f3 he
definitely has some compensation there
so it's their rookie am is interesting
anyway i can take here first Queen f5 is
this kind of logical looking move I have
96 I think and he has no check
they are tricky to play with my poopy
bad King position
yeah it's hard to anticipate legs move
now there are a couple of ideas okay so
okay 720 f5 doesn't does it lead to much
maybe Queen f23 here or here just
covering that F 5 square threatening a
look at seven maybe it's a bit slow it
could be a good prophylactic move okay
okay seven now right driving repairing
the Queen back
that shouldn't be too bad
skiing of his queen is completely boxed
in and I don't see a better move than
look at it ok this one and then we'll
get fate maybe time morning so now that
a way to get in there I cannot trap the
queen or anything I would love to get
into that point if c 7 a-7 i don't see
how maybe just this one here I mean he
cannot move his Queen anyway now this
opens up this diagonal here to f2 one
such a [ __ ] why did I allow that
probably it's not an objective problem
but it's a practical problem god damn it
I really hate it here to screw up
totally winning position before it was
so utterly stupid check it was a
position where I had to complete control
William there was absolutely nothing
that he had her head had left down check
check
I what an idiotic game I really hate
this stuff like resins absolutely
idiotic I mean is so utterly bus today I
can play everything the queen is
stalemated on the aid and I find the
absolutely only move that gifts gives
him some remote chance of play it's
really remarkable this is a plus 4
million position here I mean it's
probably not even objectively bad it's
just it just totally unnecessary a 22 to
give him that opportunity this is sis's
sis's almost like help made young no
words no words ah and now please stop
moving absolutely I come on you know
anymore you know you paint some damn
arrows in this position yeah I know that
I'm totally winning here you don't need
to show me ok so let's have a look at
this it was a very interesting position
definitely enter around here so went
back and now it get got technically very
interesting i played this move and this
allows a couple of things this night
before or Bishop before move and again
he ultimately played this the computer
wants to play my t4 intern finds this to
keep the position okay for black with
the round equal play yeah that it makes
sense I also thought this was
interesting but probably I can just do
this and play the position this position
here
now the engine gives night h5 and says
black is okay yeah it's difficult to do
something else okay maybe I can just
move the night I can't act like this
that might be a possibility no this this
kind of thing I can take yeah that's
very nice the two nights are strong okay
went with this I played King edge to
this was a bit of a scary move
definitely because I thought that this
is working and it probably is the
computer wants to play wow yeah this is
difficult as saw the line but I couldn't
really believe that is good the computer
wants to do this which is I saw that but
I wasn't it looks at look too weird to
me but there seems to be nothing great
for black this is what the engine is
giving really funny line right here why
does sound probably better you choose D
poem Tim flower stuff ok this is not
good because of 94 which she did not
play 94 yeah i was thinking i can go
here but now the engine gives a bishop
age three and takes a night f2 cual
that's brutal yeah that's very strong it
didn't play that you played now
officially before and after that the
position gets better for wide yeah
Quincy to probably not a bad move just
preventing any Queen f5 and after night
age five I get this this winning
position here yeah okay everything winds
basically but before before it's just
completely idiotic you can never move
this Queen yet in this position yum yeah
the computer wants to do this
then play 96 and probably win the queen
but it doesn't it really doesn't matter
I can play absolutely everything here
just have to avoid giving him this space
this idea with Queen B 6 that he can
start to make threats in the time troll
I can play whatever you just activate
the queen or what it really doesn't
matter the Queen has stalemated and now
I was already totally pissed that I had
allowed this thing Queen B to still
seems to be good and after this the
tides is to Stuart is turning completely
now no I'm in trouble my king is just
too weak and black is winning here and
Queen h4 was winning before and check
check but what he played is good enough
it's just it's just too bad rook c4 was
better no but okay I had no time and I
was I was already pretty pissed him that
this was happening yeah very bad before
okay thanks for watching